let's go to the phones a lot of people
holding a lot of people want to check in
today six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty is the number we're
going to start with our caller from the
five seven one area code caller from
five seven one say hello
tell us who you are and what's on your
mind today when you say your name is
Robert it's very very windy and tough to
hear you try to speak up if you forget
if you can
my name is Grover Grover okay Grover
what's going on I have a question why
don't you guys like I mean if you know
filly defranco sexually are things I
know about the most about the videos or
you are not getting money furnace yeah
but don't you guys like create an app or
kind of make a union stuff total and
presented to you too and so although
they can review yours all your videos
together yeah make it easier for you
guys um you know be able to receive
money and that way and the other
question that I have is about you
lawsuit I think are that thing going
okay good so Grover let me address each
of these issues in it's all very good
questions by the way and let's turn
Grover up as much as we can just so
everybody can hear him so number one we
I could go and try to join with some
other youtubers but the truth is we
really don't have leverage over YouTube
and we can't get YouTube to do anything
even together 5 10 20 30 progressive
youtubers we are tiny when it comes to
the total YouTube universe so to do what
you're suggesting Grover which is a
great idea you need new tech
infrastructure you actually need to
build something that would allow that to
happen and it would be very expensive
for us to do and there's no reason
whatsoever that YouTube would agree to
do it themselves or even to work with us
on it because they just don't need to
that's the truth that's how big they are
okay so sad I know it's I can hear
you're bummed out but it is what it is
now as far as the lawsuit goes you're
referring to we were threatened with a
lawsuit yeah some time ago and I
mentioned it we were demanded thousands
of dollars and then I basically said at
that point I'm not going to say much
about it for now but I hope to one day
be able to tell the story I don't want
to say too much but we are getting very
close to be able being able to tell the
story okay and I just want to my
understanding is that it's wrapping up I
actually spoke to my lawyer about this
today but until I get the all-clear that
we can talk about it I don't want to say
anything else but I will talk about it
when I can Grover last thing I wanted to
show you uh3 is pre-production
yeah they go I don't know if you heard
about it I just I mean I am NOT a lawyer
myself but you could speak to them they
might be able to help you out with your
losses and they're just a reference that
I'm giving yes 3 H 3 I know ethan klein
over there
but fortunately Grover I would if we
needed to but I think that we are
getting beyond the lawsuit thing so I
don't think we need anybody else's help
at this time but yeah Ethan Ethan's a
good guy and a good person to speak to
all right Grover always great to hear
from you thank you so much